It's ya boy - Markimoo.
And then we got...
*FOXY!!!*
Are you staring at my beautiful face?
I know I'm really pretty.
"It's goin' down!
I'm yelling timber!"
WOAH! WHOLY! FUCKING NO!
THAT'S A BIG NO!
You there?
AHH! WHAT THE FUCK! GO THEN!
And I always look good!
I'm me!
Look at these!
Look at THESE bazongas!
Look at THIS bazonga!
*BAAAM*
I'm lookin' for secrets. I'm like the
GAME THEORIZER.
GO! TIME!! GO!!!
I got a light!
*steps*
Don't do it...!
*COME HERE!*
AAAAUGHHHHH!!!
I hear. Noises. In the Dorkness.
I don't know why any noise is happening ri-
SHUT UP, SCOTT!
Am I supposed to do something about this?!
This seems highly irregular!
Goooooood!
Whatever that was!
Gooooo-
AHH! AAAHH! WOAAHH!
WHAT THE FUCK!?!
WHAT IS THAT?!!
Today is the day I WIN!
Because I... am the king AROUND HERE!
And nobody will take my CROWN!
I'll kiss you!
I'll suck your balls.
I'll do something. Literally anything!
NO! NOT YOU!! NOT YOUR BALLS!!!
BB: "Hello" (and laughs)
Oh, fuck.
I- I think it broke. Did it break?
It's looking at me, isn't it?
I just- *boop* Oh!
Oh, fuck...
BB: "Hello!"
AHHH!
Did I like fall through the flo-
WOAH! WHY?! Wha... uh... WHY?! CAN I-
WHA- I saw little bit! So you're just fucking with me!!
UH! AH! AHH! OH! OH GOD!
*HI MARKIMOO!*
AHH! STOP IT!
Hey! Listen! Buddy! Listen, okay? I can see now.
*NOW HUG ME BUDDY!*
AAAAAHHHHHH!
So, I've got this on lock!
The shock factor is over.
(Some relaxing music)
NO!! NO! WAIT! HANG ON! STOP!
YOU DON'T WANNA DO THIS!
Listen! I been a good boy!
I BEEN A GOOD BOY! PLEASE!
I bean such a good boy! DON'T DO IT!
NNNNOOOOOOOOOOO!!
(Deep and distorted) "ThE sHoCk FaCtOr Is OvEr".
Is that an original 1982 lithuanian lard?
Plushbaby: "I guess you forgot about me."
Who? Where?! Why?!! What???! Who??!! Where??!! And why?! WHO?! AND WHERE?! AND WHY?!?!
*SURPRISE MOTHERFUCKER!*
AHHH!!
Listen, buddy. Listen.
*swallowed*
AHH! WHAT DEH WHE-
WHAT THE FUCK!? DID I EAT THAT?!! O_O
You don't mess with me!
'Cause I won't mess with you!
And you don't want these messing fingers MESSING with you, Chica! (Don't yell at your dog!)
You run like a little baby in the face of pure death!!
These fingers spell DEATH!
Stopping that! You- Go ahead! Try!
"Try me, bitch!"
I need to do parts and service for Bonnie.
Which means I gotta touch Bonnie all over...
And I deh- you know...
I gotta f- *beep* Bonnie.
OH MY GOD! You are fucking huge!
Oh my god... Look at your LEG!
WHAT ARE THOSE!?
Alright, here we go.
Oh fuck me...
Oh shit...
Ooh...
*KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF ME! YOU CREEP!*
Ooh- BWAHHA!!!
Now, there's only two levels that I can see and I'm pretty sure I can count to two.
One... and the other number that I don't know.
Oh, surely, they must be joking.
Oh, surely.
SURELY, they must be telling the jokes here.
Surely, they must be saying the jokes.
That looks likes Squidward.
HandUnit: "Take it."
What if I don't?
What happens if I don't?
How about what if I don't?
HandUnit: "Eat it."
Nah, I don't know if I wanna, I'm not hungry.
Are your eyes...? Oh yeah.
HandUnit: "Eat it."
I- Well- I-
Don't tell me to eat it. That's just rude.
Number one, number two...
HandUnit: "Eat it."
*jumpscare*
AHHH! FUCK! GOD! FU-
Awwwwww!
Really?!
.̡͂҉͉̪͙̫̲.͎̦͈̿̅̏̅ͯ̈́͋ͩͩ.̶̯͇̿̀̚E.̶̯͇̿̀̚A.̶̯͇̿̀̚T ̤̻̫ͦ̾̈͆̆̎ͭͩI̤̻̫ͦ̾̈͆̆̎ͭͩ.̶̯͇̿̀̚T̤̻̫ͦ̾̈͆̆̎ͭͩ.
Oh, they MUST be joking!
Woah, they MUST be joking! Oh-
AHH! OH FUCKING GOD!!!
Well, you know, we're all good after I repaired you, right?
"Oh yeah!"
*swallowed again*
BWA- FUCKING GOOOOOOOOOOOOO-
Surely, you must be joshing.
You must be reciting those HILARIOUS jokes!
The likes of which have only been told in rumors and legends!
Alright, tape time!
I like tapes!
You... are big.
And I am ssssss- mmm-
Average.
I'm average.
Whatever, nerd. Yeah, you comin', nerd?
What's this? Squidward? Oh, how you? You ain't a nerd, are yah?
Oh, what's that I hear? A nerd approaching?
Well, come at me!
NERD!!
God, fucking sticky fingers!
Сan I, please, deer for the love of... jahubasus!
For the love of... great BIG BAZONGAS!
Ah, is that a nerd over there?
NNNN-nerd?
En-nerd.
Ohhh, aren't you pretty? I'm gonna play with you.
Do-re-li-do.
*disappeared*
Oh.
No.
No!
NOOOOOO-!
"I'm going to eat your soul right out your ass!"
Uh, did you just threatened to eat my ass?
GET ME! COME ON!!!
KILL ME! I'll put my head in your mouth!
BB: Hi! Mark: When I'm alone on a thursday night, this is how I do.
Doo-da le le le le.
Yeah, yeah! You close? You close?
"It's me! With the melty eyes!"
(Singing) ♪ La la ♪
♪ Help me ♪
♪ I am very ♪
♪ con-fused ♪
*singing Ave Maria*
Omae wa mou shindeiru.
(You are already dead.)
Nani?!
(What?!) UGH!
Man, I got a problem.
I should probably be worried about that.
HandUnit: "A perfect 72 degrees. See you next time."
AHHH!
I didn't get any-
OOWWW! WOAH! WEOW! WOOAW! HEY! HEY! WOOOAW!
*thump*
What?!
I'm sorry...
For what was probably the most spastic gameplay footage you've ever seen in your life.
What I'm not sorry for...
Is the amount of poop in my pants.